The governor of Russians Belgorod regions of the
counterterrorism operations are ongoing after
a rare attack on Russian. Soil >> Two groups of
anti-putin, Russian fighters aligned with Ukraine
are claiming responsibility for that assault in
the region, which borders Ukraine. CNN's Matthew
chance has the details [speaking non-english]
>> Tonight,
Russian forces insist that
taking back control. From a
group of what they call saboteurs,
infiltrating this leafy border.
These images purporting to show a Russian soldier
detaining three of them with -- your broadcast
on state media.
[Speaking non-english]
Meet the anti Kremlin Russians.
Taking the fight back home.
[Speaking non-english] This is how we work,
he says, amid a bold armored raid across
[4:09:50 AM]
amid a bold armored raid across the
Ukrainian border into Russia itself.
CNN can't independently verify any of the
images, but this entire column of vehicles was
spotted crossing the frontier. Ukrainian forces
insisted it's not them, but exiled Russian groups
fighting against the Kremlin.
[Speaking non-english]
>> Translator: We are Russians, just like
you. We want our children to grip in peace
and be free so they can travel, study,
and be happy. But this is impossible in
Putin's Russia.
>> Translator:
And the rate called Russian border guards
unawares. This one tried to be a hero, the writer
says, amid scattered passports and a portrait
of Vladimir Putin overlooking the carnage below.
[Speaking non-english] The border is
now unlocked, says one of the fighters.
[4:10:50 AM]
says one of the fighters. Grandpa
Putin will soon turn to honey,
says the other. In other words, die.
[Speaking non-english] On Kremlin
control television, the presenters stood
like statues as the day's events replay.
♪♪ ♪♪ on videos from stunned
locals, witnessing the fight. The
Kremlin called the attack a diversion but already
the sharp criticism from Russian hard-liners that
this was allowed to occur.
[Sirens] This
Russian region, right next to Ukraine, is
no stranger to cross border attacks. But
armed incursions like this are rare. And the mood
here, according to local Rochelle officials, has
shifted. With empty buses coming into evacuate
residents, while those who can leaving by
themselves. Matthew chance, CNN, London.
[4:11:57 AM]
Matthew chance, CNN, London.
>> And if that story gets out,
and Russian media, how is he going to explain
that Russian soldiers are attacking him?
>> Yes, that would be interesting to see.
>> Russia's deputy defense -- science minister,
rather, has died after feeling ill on a plane
and Saturday. That's according to the ministry of
science and a higher education. The Putin critic
was part of a Russian delegation returning from
business trip to Kyiv, on the plane made
an emergency landing in southern Russia,
where doctors unsuccessfully tried to
treat. The cause of death is not known,
but an autopsy is scheduled for Wednesday.
>> CNN's Salma Abdelaziz is following the
developments, and joins us with the latest.
Salma, tell us what you know. And also, I was
surprised there would be any latitude for a
[4:12:57 AM]
would be any latitude for a critic of
the Kremlin within the government in Russia.
>> Well, throughout this conflict there have
been moments where we've heard from, I'll give
you the example of state owned energy companies,
where, lukoil, that's the one I'm mentioning
here, openly criticize the conflict in Ukraine.
There have been moments of course, especially
at the beginning of this conflict, where there
have been voices of dissent. But the result of
that has been a string of murky deaths. And this
latest death is pyotr kucherenko. He's a senior
local lawmaker. Easy empty minister of science
and education. And what we understand took place,
according to the ministry of information page,
is he was returning from a business trip in
Cuba. He fell ill on the plane. The plane
landed in southern Russia, right near the border
with Georgia. He was treated, and according to the
ministry's website, he died. Now, members of
his family have indicated potentially that it
[4:13:58 AM]
indicated potentially that it could've been a
heart condition, a heart issue. But this is being
treated as suspicious, because he was known to
have criticize president Putin, most recently to
a very prominent journalist, Roman super, who said
he spoke to him just days before this business
trip to Cuba. He says that in that phone call,
he expressed, this lawmaker expressed serious
concerns about the safety. He said he was afraid
for his life. He said that he was essentially
a hostage of the Kremlin, that his passport
was taken away, that he had no control of his
movements. He said he was distressed and pressed.
He is taking tranquilizers antidepressants,
so, painting a very worrying picture here.
I want to pull up this graphic that shows
you about a dozen different officials,
businessmen, just since the beginning
of last year. So, right around the time
of the start of the invasion of Ukraine,
who have all died or fell, you know,
met their death in an apparent suicide.
[4:14:59 AM]
in an apparent suicide. I want to know the case of
one of them, rabble mom of, he died in September
after falling out the window of a hospital.
He was a chairman for one of these energy
companies, lukoil, and he had expressed dissent,
criticism, of president Putin's war in Ukraine.
Again, Russia is not claiming responsibility.
It will not claim responsibility. But they just
just -- this just adds that climate of fear, the
fact that there is consequences if you speak up.
>> It also would not be the first time that
U.S. Law, uk intelligence services have
A retired U.S. Army colonel who is a prominent
member of the council foreign relations,
he's also the coauthor of understanding
urban warfare. Thank you for joining us.
>> You're welcome.
>> So there've been similar if not more -- pro
Ukrainian anti Putin Russian fighters. But is
this one the more recent one, is a significant?
And is it a step up from previous attacks? And
how serious should they be taken when a spokesman
tells CNN they want to, quote, liberate
our mother then from the tyranny of Putin.
>> In terms of the conflict in Ukraine it's
not going to significantly impact the tactical
operation there. But in terms of Russia, I think
it's significant. This is a sizable attack by
Russian citizens on Russian territory. So Putin
doesn't have -- as you would like the world to
[1:05:42 AM]
as you would like the world to believe. But if
they can demonstrate they can do this repeatedly,
then it's definitely going to impact the fight.
They have to do it repeatedly for Russia to divert
combat forces from Ukraine to their border.
>> There might be trouble brewing at home
for Putin. . There is victory
for him in name in Ukraine.
In bakhmut when -- some of her time that
there is some strategic value to bakhmut,
does Putin have the manpower in the
resources to use the city to try
to move his forces into the donetsk region?
>> Absolutely not. This is a city that really
has little tactical and no strategic value.
Putin will no doubt try to sell this as a win,
but this is not the success they're trying
to sell it does. And when you look at,
it is unmitigated disaster for the Russians. It
took him ten months of heavy fighting just to take
this really small city, a little tactical value
in that process he lost ten, maybe hundreds or
[1:06:44 AM]
he lost ten, maybe hundreds or thousands of
soldiers at the expense of great ammunition
that is not easily replaced. So really,
they were -- is very debatable based on
how much it took just to take it and how
long it took to take. And >> I want you
to listen to the Ukrainian president,
who is taking questions from reporters
over the weekend at the g7 summit, areas.
>> Mister president, is buckman still in Ukraine's
hands? The Russian city taken bakhmut.
>>
I think, no. But you have to understand
that there is nothing. They've destroyed
everything. There are no buildings.
It's a victory, it's a tragedy,
but for today bakhmut is only in our hearts.
>> There's nothing really left of the city
which seems of little value. And maybe
in zelenskyy's heart, but the Ukrainians
tried to retake bakhmut? Is there any value to
that? Or is a -- focus on the counter offensive?
>> Ukraine has shown throughout
the war they will attack places
[1:07:47 AM]
the war they will attack places of their
choosing cause they're a smaller military.
So they will attack where they, can and they
will try to preserve combat power and they've
done that effectively throughout. So they
won't retake what is left of bakhmut unless
they feel like there's a strategic position
to do that. But I wouldn't expect them to do
that because I think they're gonna launch
the counter offensive in other locations
where the Russians -- but the powers not mast.
>> And prigozhin, the head of the mercenary group,
he claimed victory in bakhmut. I want to utilize
interpretive what he suddenly begins here
addressing Ukrainian soldiers. Here he is.
[Speaking non-english]
>> Translator: Without sarcasm, your guys fought
bravely. Fought well. And if you follow this path,
then you can become the second
term in the world. Of course,
after the most powerful army in the world,
that is Wagner pmc. Today, when you see Biden,
because some of the top of the head, say
hello for me. >> He did not say the Russian
[1:08:47 AM]
>> He did not say the Russian military is
the best in the world, but his -- political
win for prigozhin or for Putin?
>> Again, it would be hard to say if it's a
political win for Putin's
at all. It's for prigozhin,
he's trying to sell it as a win but again
this just shows a destruction in the Russian
military. You have this private army that all
the conflict that's causing with him and -- it
shows the lack of unity among the Russian command.
>> Prigozhin seems to be using this as a corn to
springboard to -- is that how it's being read?
>> I mean that's how a lot of people are
interpreting this. Of course that's a fine line
-- a political rival. So he's gotta walk that fine